JEDEDIAH: A BIG VICTORY FOR THE
GOP IN THE HOUSE THIS WEEK.
REPUBLICAN NICOLE MALLIOTAKIS,
FLIPPING NEW YORK’S 11th
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT RED.
REPUBLICANS HAVE FLIPPED 10
SEATS IN THE HOUSE WITH EIGHT OF
THEM WON BY FEMALE CANDIDATES.
CONGRESSWOMAN ELECT NICOLE
MALLIOTAKIS JOINS US NOW.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR VICTORY.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, WHAT DO YOU
THINK WAS THE CHIEF REASON FOR
THAT VICTORY IN I GREW UP IN
STATEN ISLAND, I HEARD FROM A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT IT WAS THE
DEFUND THE POLICE MOVEMENT ON
THE LEFT THAT TERRIFIED THEM?
>> LOOK OUR CITY IS MOVING MORE
AND MORE TO THE LEFT.
PEOPLE ARE SEEING CRIME
INCREASING, QUALITY OF LIFE
DETERIORATING.
THE OUR MAYOR KEEPS HAMMINGER US
OVER THE HEAD WITH HIGH TAXES.
PEOPLE HAT ENOUGH OF ONE PARTY
DEMOCRAT RULE.
THIS WAS TO SPEAK OUT THAT
NEW YORK HAS ONE REPUBLICAN
REPRESENTING OUR CITY IN
WASHINGTON.
JEDEDIAH: TELL ME ABOUT THERE
FREEDOM SQUAD THAT YOU HAVE AN
IDEA FOR.
>> WE DON’T HAVE A NAME YET
BECAUSE WE’RE NOT IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
I GOT TO TELL YOU THAT THERE IS
NATURAL ALLIANCE OCCURRING HERE,
WE’RE BONDED BY THE FACT WE COME
FROM DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES OF
SOCIALISM.
MY MOTHER WAS A CUBAN REFUGEE
WHO FLED THE CASTRO REGIME IN
1959.
CARLOS GIMENEZ IS CUBAN BORN.
HE CAME TO THE AGE OF AMERICA AT
SIX.
VICTORIA COMES FROM THE UKRAINE,
GREW UP UNDER SOVIET UNION RULE.
YOU HAVE MARIA SALAZAR WHO IS
LIKE ME, THE DAUGHTER OF CUBAN
REFUGEES.
SO WE HAVE A NATURAL ALLIANCE
THAT IS FORMING.
WE’RE BONDED BY OUR LOVE OF
AMERICA, A LOVE FOR FREEDOM AND
LIBERTY.
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT THE
AMERICAN DREAM REPRESENTS.
WE WANT TO PRESERVE THAT WE MUST
PUSH BACK AGAINST THE FORCES WHO
ARE TRYING TO DESTROY THAT.
JEDEDIAH: YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU WILL FACE
WHEN IT COMES TO ISSUES RIGHTED
PARTICULARLY TO NEW YORK IS THIS
MASSIVE EXODUS FROM NEW YORK
CITY AMID THE CORONAVIRUS, AMID
AN UP TICK IN CRIME.
IT HAS BEEN PRETTY ASTOUNDING.
IF YOU LOOK AT NUMBERS, NEW YORK
CITY LOCALS LEAVING OVER THE
PAST EIGHT MONTHS.
295,000 MARCH CHANGE OF REQUESTS
FROM MARCH 1st TO
OCTOBER 21st, 2020.
WHAT CAN BE DONE AND RECTIFY
THAT TO BRING NEW YORK BACK.
>> GOES BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
POINT.
PEOPLE SEEING CRIME INCREASE,
SAYING WACKY BAIL LAW THAT TOOK
EFFECT, LED TO SHARP INCREASE IN
MURDER AND SHOOTINGS AND
BURGLARIES AS WELL AS CAR
THEFTS.
PEOPLE FEEL LESS SAFE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THE QUALITY OF LIFE IS
DETERIORATING WITH THE MASTIFF
SHUTDOWNS.
BROAD KAY IS SHUT DOWN.
YOU CAN’T GO TO MADISON SQUARE
GARDEN.
RESTAURANTS ARE SUFFERING.
STORES ARE BOARDED UP BECAUSE OF
FEAR OF LOOTERS.
PEOPLE ARE GENERALLY CONCERNED.
WE HAVE TO INSURE THAT WE HAVING
A REAL DIALOGUE WITH
MAYOR DE BLASIO AND GOVERNOR
CUOMO ABOUT THE IMPACTS THEIR
SHUTDOWNS AND RESTRICTIONS ARE
HAVING ON OUR ECONOMY, MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A BALANCED
APPROACH TO REOPENING.
OF COURSE PUBLIC SAFETY IS
PARAMOUNT BUT WE CAN’T DESTROY
OUR CITY AND DRIVE PEOPLE OUT OR
ELSE WE’LL BE IN A VERY, VERY
BAD SITUATION COME THIS TIME
NEXT YEAR.
SO FOR ME IT IS ABOUT PROVIDING
A COUNTERVIEW TO WHAT THE MAYOR
AND GOVERNOR ARE DOING.
ENSURING WE WORK TOGETHER TO
FIND COMMON GROUND.
MAKE SURE WE KEEP OUR ECONOMY
OPEN AND VIBRANT AND KEEP
NEW YORKERS HERE.
THE MIDDLE CLASS HAD ENOUGH AND
LEAVING IN DROVES.
JEDEDIAH: WE DIDN’T GET TO IT
TODAY, BUT OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE THE
10:00 P.M. CURFEW ROLLING IN
RESTAURANTS AND OTHER